estas familias huyen de ucrania con sus
niños enfermos
en nuestro país de donde somos ya no hay
ningún lugar que acoja a los niños no
hay pediatras y hospitales
todo ha sido bombardeado la cripta
escocesa crítica
el gallego vetas de dos huesos nuestros
la dan a polonia sólo 85 kilómetros del
ivic esta ciudad del oeste de ucrania la
menos afectada por la guerra se ha
convertido en un lugar de tránsito para
quienes buscan refugio en la unión
europea los menores con problemas
médicos pasan por el hospital pediátrico
del ibi pero algunos están muy enfermos
para viajar
hay combates aquí y allá es la guerra no
es posible tratar a los niños en estas
zonas de guerra así que nos los
trasladan
a
las últimas dos semanas han llegado 400
menores entre ellos este niño de un año
que padece una enfermedad renal su madre
dice que dejó a su marido defendiendo la
capital kiev
debemos cerrar el espacio aéreo a los
aviones de combate no queremos que
nuestros hijos sufran no se merecen esto
toda ucrania está sufriendo esta guerra
qué
en el exterior las ambulancias polacas
llegan para poner a salvo a más niños al
otro lado de la frontera
bajando con chalecos antibalas y en
convoy están evacuando a 240 pacientes
por los cadáveres polonia está aquí para
ayudar y se espera que los próximos días
más de 1000 menores lleguen a este
hospital para recibir tratamiento